but it's interesting because a lot of
a lot of times if you sell a girl like
that to submit to a guy it's like hell
is freezing over of course i can't
submit to a guy
have you heard that at all
um god
i have
but it's like
there's some it's probably the girls
that actually are independent that go
that
the fake ones they'll be like okay calm
all right let's do this well there has
to be a leader and a follower in a
relationship
even even some girls do leads
but they they don't like their the guy
though
some actually do
crazy they don't
because if they really like you they're
submitting i'm just being i don't want
to say too much but if they really like
you they're submitting and i've seen it
they'll start with that attitude that
you spoke of they'll start with the no i
don't want it they hate the idea of it
but you know
it's as we said earlier it's in the dna
it's in our course i feel like it's
possible
it's more than whispers like for a woman
to lead a woman to lead it's possible
not without it
not without resenting the guy
oh you shouldn't they shouldn't they
shouldn't be leaving i personally don't
know that
i've seen people and they look pretty
happy are your parents together yeah
your mom leads
no exactly this is my point in theory it
sounds good i know right in reality then
my your mom might lead in a way where
you think it's like your dad's lack i'm
just kind of bothered he's letting her
lead but really and truly for the most
part i think men will lead no but even
now when my dad leads i just look at him
that's because i don't know i look
forward to your generation you're the
new generation so now the times are
changing so you're looking at things
different but like we said before it's
uh it's been going on for a long time
it's a good thing times are changing
though because yeah he said the man and
we're leading a bit too like i don't
mind the man you said unless he has
sense
if he's senseless then it's pointless
for him to leave obviously
okay if a girl wants to leave she can do
that but she's not going to like the guy
thank you because
women create like we're attracted to the
trait leadership like if a woman okay
okay i'll give you an example if a guy
is a ceo and he's powerful that is hot
to us that's sexy a president that's
sexy okay ceo
and that if a man is as a woman ceo
it's cool
but it's like it's like a shoe
collection
to us
so if a dude is a shoe collection that's
cool but i don't we don't care
it's it's whatever and that's what it is
to them so
the
what we're attracted to isn't a guy
that's that's like
that doesn't have the leadership
qualities
and so it's um
yeah i mean they can do it and some
girls do but they always they always
hate their husbands
you put that so wrong i was so poignant
so true i couldn't i couldn't have said
it better myself no but then a lot of
women who hate their husbands are the
ones
that are submissive as well
pretending to be maybe
not even would you mean submissive to
their husbands
so the husband's like the lead the
leader of the relationship
and they hate them
because they say then it's the wrong
kind of leadership yeah that's yeah
that's true it depends
it's the wrong kind of leadership
we might not really be leadership it
could just be bullying or overpowering
them in a situation and then that's
wrong
a real real submission should that we're
talking obviously more kind of
do you guys think it's um
okay do you think it's fair for women to
want traditional men that pay and take
care of them and take us on dates all
that stuff well we're not traditional
women so like we're not virgins anymore
we're not like we don't offer the
traditional yeah
no i'm just saying no no i didn't hear
you go ahead if you want a traditional
man you have to be a traditional woman
like don't get mad when he expects you
to stay at bst at her mom quick and
clean and stuff like that because that's
how it works
but yeah
that's why i don't want a traditional
man because i know it comes with that
price
at the price of i really i would
if i could stay home i'd be chilling
at home all day oh yeah i mean look
after the kids cook clean when he comes
in washes yeah watch his underwear like
that's just again i'm going to ask did
your mom do that stuff
yes
yes
i don't like that
you're fighting against you're fighting
against it but it's there for you to see
and it's been successful your parents
are still together because they're
successful just because they're together
doesn't mean it's successful that's true
that's not something i inspire you so
i'm asking you know your parents have so
you're saying they're not they can't be
happy but i wasn't the happiness the
success i mean like for you for them not
for you for them yeah but for me
that's not what i
personally i understand i'm just i'm
just saying for them they've achieved
happiness for them yeah
you don't think that's an indicator of
success
that's the point i'm trying to make yeah
but it's like 50 of marriages end in
divorce so the fact that your parents
are still together and don't hate each
other is a w